bring you uh some breaking news that's
coming into us here at Sky News in the
metropolitan police have announced the
name of the eight-year-old girl who was
killed in that crash at the study
Preparatory School in Wimbledon on
Thursday the Metropolitan Police say her
name was Selena Lao
and her family have released a statement
it says Selena was an intelligent and
cheeky girl adored and loved by everyone
the family wishes their privacy to be
respected that this sad time sling
allowed was eight and that's an
end-of-year party when there was a crash
at her school another eight-year-old
girl is in a life-threatening condition
as is a 40 year old woman the person
driving the vehicle a 46 year old woman
and was arrested on suspicion of causing
death by dangerous driving but has been
bailed until late July